Bud Light continues to collapse Bud
Light sails have declined 23.6 percent
in the week ending May 6th relative to
the same period last year this is an
even worse decline than for the week
ending April 29th which was an even
worse decline than the week before and
the week before and the week before
Budweiser Bud heavy sales have fallen
11.4 percent the week ending April 29th
and 9.7 weekend in May 6th Michelob
Ultra fell 4.3 percent 2.9 respectively
Natty light have has fallen 5.2 percent
and 2.5 percent respectively so all of
those companies are feeling that
Downstream effects of Bud Light and they
continue to lose ground though at least
for them it seems to be leveling off for
Bud Light not only are they losing sales
massively it's still getting worse